I have never been knowledgeable in
accounting or bookkeeping in any
business that I've ever owned since day
one I've always outsourced bookkeeping
and this is just a really simple example
because a lot of entrepreneurs are like
I have to do everything myself I have to
learn everything but like you don't
normally learn accounting some people do
but like most don't you can still apply
that same mental framework to any
Department of the business it's just
that most of us think we need to know
all of these things but you don't you
need to know how to recognize that
talent in somebody else and then
encourage them and create an environment
where they feel safe that they can just
execute that at the highest level on
your behalf